Then we get into the small intestine and then it even gets into the small intestine and the large intestine
It even gets more interesting because we have all these little beasties that are living inside of us that are helping us
So this is called your normal flora or what the new term is your microbiata
So your new this flora that lives in your gut has hundreds of millions of different organisms that work
symbiotically with us. That means they help us absorb different nutrition
They help us digest different things and they help fight infection
So this is your second line of defense against foodborne pathogens. So H. Pylora is actually
There's certain strains of H. Pylora that are normal in your flora
So in the right balance everything that's right balance even E. Coli. Oh, I had an E. Coli infection
It was really sick E. Coli as normal in your flora in the right balance
So remember when we talk about health and sickness and even things that I'll talk about today
We talk about oh, this is bad and this is good, but in reality. There's not really bad or good
It's bad or good when it gets out of balance
So as inflammation bad. Oh, yes, inflammation is bad
But wait a second the TH1 response to kill off a pathogen produces inflammation. That's not bad
Well, I guess it's not bad there. So there's not so much bad or good
It's it's the concentration that we're really talking about. It's that imbalance that we're talking about and in balance in our gut flora
We could say causes a
Huge percentage of disease and at least it's present in a huge percentage of disease whichever came first
We don't fully know
But this is a big big player if we don't rebalance the gut flora
We're gonna have all sorts of problems
Because the gut flora does a lot of things to keep us healthy
So normally what happens is that we consume food and if we're consuming a good diet and
We talk about alkalizing our tissues
So what's the best way to alkalize our tissue besides using a rife machine which is an electron donor
Which will alkalize the tissue directly is eating a good diet. So we're eating greens we're eating vegetables
We're eating organically
And by doing that it's it's allowing our body to produce
Alkalinity
Raising the pH of tissues. Well, how does it exactly do that? Well, this
Picture right here. I don't know if I point to her works. It doesn't work on this thing
So that that line of cells right there is your
Epithelial cells in your intestinal wall
Your intestinal wall cells are actually a single layer of cells that go around your intestinal wall
And if you can think of them as your skin
So many times we think of when we eat something it's inside of our body
But actually it's not really inside of our body until we absorb it
So just like our skin is a protective layer so that we don't get bacteria
Into our body
It's a it's a layer that keeps things I can stick my hand in a thing of gasoline
That's not so good because I will absorb some of it
But it does keep most of the gasoline out of my blood street
So it is with our intestinal
Epithelial layer these the cell layer that protects us from the outside world if you can think of what's inside your gut right now
It's really in the outside world and it'll help us understand this a little bit better
That intestinal layer is keeping things outside of us so
Mercury is not good for us right
So you shouldn't eat fish with mercury in it right not a good thing
But you don't have absorption sites for mercury so if we just think about this second should we eat fish with mercury probably not a good idea
However, we really shouldn't absorb any of it
If I had a really healthy gut wall I could eat fish with mercury and it would just be deposited in the toilet a few hours later
Because I don't have absorption sites for mercury. I shouldn't absorb it
Problem comes in is that when I've damaged my gut wall now things get across the gut wall that never should have
However, it's a single layer of cells and then the cells are together in what's called a gap junction
In the intestinal walls we call that a tight gap junction
And that's perfect example because when we damage our gut wall that tight gap junction is not so tight anymore
It starts to separate the cells are damaged. They start to necrosse. They start to
balloon out they start to break down and they start to have this gap in between so things get across the gut wall
That never should have got across the gut wall